[Music]
on this wednesday night keeping a
promise
the uk calls canada's pledge to resettle
20 000 afghans aspirational so what is
the timeline and how many is canada
really rescuing from the taliban we
cannot accommodate 20 000 people all in
one go i spoke to the canadians last
night came they can't plus the afghans
already here fear time is running out
for their loved ones right now you're
just trying to save their lives the
major general who ran canada's vaccine
rollout charged with sexual assault this
arrest warrant
was a total surprise
plus to boost or not to boost ontario's
plan for a third dose is it the right
thing to do when much of the world still
waits for a first dose
and a tory majority what a progressive
conservative win in nova scotia may mean
for the federal race
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
on the road to the airport in kabul a
crush of people still live in hope
enduring taliban warning shots to clear
the road these people have heard the
promises from the west and know the
airport is their only lifeline to a
taliban-free future
good evening and thanks for joining us
the u.s military says it now has taken
control of kabul airport and secured
both the civilian and military sides
flights are operating the u.s says it
has airlifted out about 2 000 people in
the last 24 hours india the uk and
holland also got people out though there
are reports some flights are leaving
with many empty seats the taliban
control everything else in the city it
has set up checkpoints across the
capital and near the airport reportedly
beating and intimidating some afghans
though the taliban is escorting some
convoys of foreign evacuees to the
airport including citizens from the u.s
and india redmond shannon has tonight's
top story on the race to escape and the
emerging signs of resistance to taliban
rule
a taliban flag on a u.s made humvee
outside the british embassy there is no
doubt about who is in control now
taliban leaders sit down with the man
who led the country until 2014 hamid
karzai as the group looks to form a
government the system of the government
is clear that is an islamic government
sharia law would be of course there will
be no democratic system at all
in kandahar once the base of canadian
forces in the country taliban members
celebrate the return of co-founder mula
baradar from his exile in qatar
[Music]
speaking from exile in the united arab
emirates outgoing president ashraf ghani
says he fled to avoid being lynched but
his vice president amrola saleh insists
he is the new rightful leader asking
afghans to join the resistance against
what he calls taliban terrorists
anti-taliban march in the city of
jalalabad was met with gunfire at least
three people were killed reports across
the country say taliban members have
been knocking on doors checking people's
identities the uk like canada has
promised to accept around 20 000 afghan
refugees britain's interior minister
gave the first indication of details of
canada's resettlement timeline
we cannot accommodate 20 000 people all
in one go we have to have this well
actually i spoke to the canadians last
night kane they can't on tuesday mps
packed the british house of commons for
the first time in the pandemic prime
minister boris johnson facing scathing
words even from his own mps during an
emergency sitting of parliament well
where is our foreign policy determined
here
or in washington i do find it
incomprehensible and worrying that the
united kingdom was not able to bring
together not a military solution but an
alternative alliance of countries but
this is a shame on all of us not just
america but also the whole of nato the
prime minister told mps that the taliban
would be judged on their actions and not
their words but johnson didn't outline
what the consequences of that judgment
would be redmond shannon global news
london
what about that promise by canada to
resettle more than 20 000 afghans is it
aspirational as britain's home secretary
revealed and will it include the people
who fear they are in imminent danger
from the taliban including interpreters
and other contractors who worked for
canada mercedes stephenson is traveling
with the prime minister who is
campaigning in vancouver
mercedes did he offer any clarity on
this
well donna we asked the prime minister
and we didn't really get a clear answer
despite the fact he keeps talking about
that 20 000 number so i spent today
digging into this to find out what's
what here's the deal the 20 000 number
are not new positions that are being
created for afghans they're within
existing quotas so kind of like how you
would make reservations in a dining room
for a certain table this will reserve
twenty thousand of canada's existing
spots for refugees from afghanistan but
it doesn't add new spots on top of that
and it's for people who have already
fled the country or those who are able
to get out it will not be a rescue
mission to bring out people who are on
the ground canada will also accept those
interpreters and those who worked
closely for canada that will be on top
of the twenty thousand and those are the
folks who are going to be going and
actually rescuing from kandahar airfield
but unlike the americans it won't be a
situation where anyone who wants to get
on one of our planes to come as a
refugee can now one of the big questions
is how do you even get out of the
country or get to the airport there's
been a lot of criticism of the
government on this because they haven't
provided much information or have
provided very complex documents here's
what the prime minister had to say about
that today the limiting factor on this
is not uh paperwork or not connections
with the canadian government the
limiting factor on getting people out of
afghanistan right now is people being
unable to get to the airport people
being unable to actually leave the
country
immigration lawyers who we spoke to
though say there's no hotline there
doesn't appear to be a clear application
process and it's becoming very confusing
for those who are on the ground in
afghanistan and those here in canada who
are hoping to bring family members to
join them
okay and mercedes i want to ask you
about the news that broke today major
general danny forte who was leading
logistics for canada's covet 19 vaccine
rollout has been charged with one count
of sexual assault he appeared at a
gatineau quebec courthouse today
it's arrest warrant
is a total surprise
i am
reluctantly
at my own expense
[Music]
forced to pursue two forms of legal
redress
the first
to vigorously defend myself against
the charge late today
in criminal court
and second
as a federal court to consider the lack
of due process
according me
throughout this ordeal
mercedes he says this is political what
are the other layers to this story well
there's the whole issue of sexual
misconduct in the canadian armed forces
but major general forte is saying that
this was essentially a decision of
political expediency and that the
government threw him under the bus
without giving him the facts mr trudeau
was asked about that today here's what
the prime minister had to say
i'm not going to make any comments on
that because
obviously it is an ongoing
court situation
but i will repeat how incredibly
important it is that everyone who serves
in the canadian armed forces has an
environment that is safe
and supportive
the prime minister reiterated the
government's commitment to fighting
sexual misconduct in the military but
did not answer a question about why the
government is not forcing the military
to hand sexual assault and sexual
misconduct files over to civilian
authorities this will be an issue the
liberals will continue to have to deal
with on the campaign trail as one of
their former top generals and one of
their current top generals will be in
court during the election on criminal
charges
donna okay mercedes stevenson in
vancouver thanks
elections canada has laid out plans for
how canadians will vote and get results
in the federal election the chief
electoral officer says there will not be
a final outcome on september 20th
election day because of the amount of
mail-in ballots that are expected stefan
perrault says counting mail imbalance
won't start until after election day in
most locations this should be done
within two days but in some
in some districts it could take as long
as five days depending on the volume and
the distribution
elections canada says up to 5 million
canadians are expected to vote by mail
about 50 000 cast mail-in ballots in
2019 perrault says the election will be
safe even though polling officers are
not required to be vaccinated voters
will be asked to follow provincial rules
for masking and plexiglas dividers will
be in place
to vote by mail you must apply through
elections canada by september 14th and
you will not be able to change your mind
and then cast your vote in person
turning now to the campaign trail ndp
leader jug meat singh spent the day in
metro vancouver a region struggling with
skyrocketing housing prices singh says
an ndp government would build 500 000
affordable homes in 10 years and he's
vowing to bring in a one-time 20 percent
foreign home buyers tax
we want to make it so it is not at all a
viable option for big money from foreign
countries to invest in the canadian
housing market we want the canadian
housing market to be for canadians who
need a home it should not be for big
business
the conservatives make a point of
highlighting the liberals ethical issues
and today aaron o'toole unveiled his
plan for accountability it includes
bigger fines and a block on mps
accepting speaking fees but a different
question of accountability has been
dogging his own campaign how he will
handle unvaccinated candidates abigail
beeman is on the conservative campaign
in quebec city abigail
donna conservatives keep stressing they
want to campaign safely during covet so
far no public events and most either
virtual or in empty hotel rooms so it
didn't quite add up that aaron o'toole
wouldn't answer questions around whether
his own candidates out campaigning are
vaccinated the other parties tackled
that issue right out of the gates
wednesday he was finally clear they have
a choice i expect my team
to follow all the public health measures
in this
justin trudeau fourth wave pandemic that
includes expectations with respect to to
vaccines or an expectation to daily
rapid testing that's the same position
o'toole is advocating when it comes to
mandatory vaccinations in general he
says canadians should have a reasonable
alternative justin trudeau wednesday
doubled down on the liberal position
that no one will be able to board a
train or plane who is unvaccinated
unless and only unless they have a
medical exemption as for conservative
candidates and anyone campaigning the
party sent out this edict tuesday
morning to all candidates making the
position clear get the shot or take a
daily rapid test it includes links for
where local campaigns can order tests
noticeably absent from that directive
was any follow-up mechanism the party
couldn't say how or even if this
so-called expectation would be enforced
and doing so would certainly be a tall
order donna all right abigail beeman on
the conservative campaign thanks
a lot of people are trying to read the
tea leaves after what happened in the
nova scotia election last night the
progressive conservatives won a majority
defeating the liberals a surprise to
many who thought another pandemic
election would be won by the incumbents
what if anything does it signal about
the federal election ross lord is
looking into that
there's nothing quite like a triumph
that's unexpected
nova scotians are placing their faith in
the progressive conservatives premier
designate tim houston the 51 year old
accountant sold them on an ambitious
agenda full of health care spending
promises and inclusivity no matter the
color of your skin
your gender
who you love how you pray or the
language you speak our pc government
will listen to you will respect you
polling suggested a close outcome but
the tories ended up with the majority of
nova scotia's 55 seats well i didn't
really see us going pc at all but
fingers across for the future
because this is a great city to live in
a great province to live in incumbent
premier ian rankin was blasted for
worsening ambulance service and failing
to fix waiting lists for doctors rankin
was also haunted by his handling of two
impaired driving incidents from years
ago and by the forced resignation of a
candidate who posted boudoir photos
online
in defeat rankin tried to focus on
positives like the government's success
against covert 19. we are leaders in
this pandemic we will be leaders in the
recovery no matter who's in government
political analysts say nova scotia
results should not automatically be
applied to the federal campaign but they
say there are lessons to be learned for
justin trudeau's liberals in some ways
we are past
the
the phase
the period of time
where
covet elections were
producing the benefit of the doubt for
incumbents regional success for
conservatives might or might not help
the federal conservatives because
houston has distanced himself from aaron
o'toole's party both in language and in
policy
ross lord global news halifax
the debate over a third dose coming up
the u.s plans to offer all adults a
third kovit 19 shot is it the right
thing to do and will canada do the same
just hours after ontario announced it
will become the first canadian province
to offer covid19 booster shots to
vulnerable people the u.s is following
suit it says all american adults over
the age of 18 will be offered a third
dose jamie morocco explains why and
whether canadian public health experts
think it's the right thing to do
heart transplant recipient mike willis
is one of few canadians who have had
three copic 19 vaccines i had
zero antibodies from the first two shots
of moderna part of a toronto-based trial
it wasn't until his booster shot the 66
year old had any protection at all with
the delta variant circulating we need to
make sure that everybody's antibodies
are at the level that they should be and
partly why u.s health officials have
decided to recommend third doses of
pfizer and moderna to all americans 18
or older eight months after their second
shot you want to stay ahead of the virus
the u.s centers for disease control say
recent data from the u.s and israel
reveals immunity to covet 19 for the
general population decreases around six
months after a second shot this happens
with all vaccines or even infections
understanding the nuances of what waning
immunity means and correlates of
protection really are going to
going to take some time the studies also
found a third mrna vaccine can boost
copin 19 antibody levels 10 fold which
dr anthony fauci called a dramatic
increase still canadian health experts
aren't convinced prioritizing boosters
domestically is the best way to fight
coven 19 globally we are not dealing
with the core of the problem and the
core of the problem is that this virus
is out there all over the planet earth
the world health organization has asked
countries like canada to hold off on
third doses until at least the end of
september canada's national advisory
committee on immunization has not
proposed boosters for the general
population but it says it is reviewing
data and will be updating its
recommendation in the coming weeks donna
all right jamie morocco in toronto
thanks record inflation in canada still
ahead what's causing it
canada's inflation rate surged in july
to its highest level since 2011. gas
prices jumped 30 percent over the last
year housing costs went up nearly 14 and
restaurant expenses rose more than 3
percent and gaviola reports on what is
triggering the inflation and what it
could lead to
more
more
more if it feels like just about
everything in your life costs more right
now you're right it does cost increases
are being driven by rising gas prices
and supply chain issues
canada's inflation rate surged to 3.7
percent in july levels we haven't seen
in a decade the pace of inflation has
been above three percent for four
straight months and if you think your
grocery bill is giving you sticker shock
now experts say there's more food
inflation to come
things are dire out west the drought and
sort of these extreme weather conditions
that arise due to climate change it will
continue to wreak havoc on food prices
this toronto restaurant owner says
rising meat protein and fresh produce
costs are hitting her bottom line we
don't want to raise our prices right now
too we understand that we are all in the
middle of a pandemic
but that's something that we might have
to be doing later on looking into fall
and winter who best addresses food
inflation and supports small businesses
will decide her vote next month well i
want to see if they have a recovery plan
how do we keep our doors open prices are
going up hydro's gone up when we ask
about affordability the ndp tends to do
better than any other party on that
issue so if affordability is the number
one issue in this election campaign it's
a good opportunity for judgment singing
the ndp ipsos polling shows that
affordability including food inflation
ranks among canadians top election
issues particularly among millennial and
gen z voters who now make up 40 percent
of the population and were instrumental
in getting justin trudeau elected in the
past
anne gaviola global news toronto
safe in canada but desperate to save
loved ones back home in afghanistan
that's next
the taliban's leaders claim they don't
want to turn afghanistan into a
battlefield again and won't impose the
same brutal rule and repression of two
decades ago it is hard to have faith in
that though especially for many afghan
refugees here in canada who still have
family back home mike draulie has been
talking to some of them
from a world away the streets of kabul
while quiet seemed peaceful the taliban
promised tolerance
but that barely lasted a day
some female journalists have now been
banned from appearing on tv leaving
afghans to wonder what measures may be
next
mina a health care worker whose identity
we agreed to conceal was forced to flee
canada after speaking out against
taliban atrocities in 2019. they killed
mothers they killed pregnant women they
killed healthcare providers they killed
newborns innocent children she was
declared a protected person by canada's
immigration board but the process to
reunite with her husband and three
children who remain in afghanistan has
been slow and cumbersome right now we
are just trying to save their lives we
don't think about the future we don't
think about about their education right
now they should be safe we should have
them alive the federal government says
it plans on opening the doors to 20 000
afghans the canadian council for
refugees says canada should have stepped
up years ago
and it is heartbreaking to think that if
canada had acted responsibly uh in the
past few years most of these people
would be safely here in canada muhammad
whose identity were also concealing
developed close ties to canada while
working in the afghan ministry of
finance that made him a target he fled
in 2019 leaving behind his wife and 10
kids six of them girls over the age of
fifteen
they're educated he says with dreams of
becoming doctors and business leaders
they're now in hiding and fear being
married off to taliban fighters
or worse
they'll call it canis you know
yeah the the that means that the you
take the woman and whatever you want you
you can use for
doesn't sound like she has any rights no
no rights
mina he's desperate for his adopted
country to step up his family's lives
are at stake
mike drolit global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen it is a
deeply uncertain time especially for
women and girls in afghanistan
and yet this group of women and some
young men won't be silenced their
message to the world afghan women are
stronger than they were 20 years ago
when the taliban last controlled
afghanistan they say we will not give up
our right to work education and
political rights and we will not give up
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you